my next guest is a talented comedian who
has both a critically acclaimed
half-hour special and album to her name
already her long-awaited debut hour
special is called
girl daddy it's on hbo max please
welcome beth stelling hello
beth
drinking the ginger buck what do you got
in your what's it called i'm having the
the it's called the the max arena
yeah out of a boot and we need these are
branded drinks i need you to say right
to the camera max read a boot and take
it to the max
and if you can make a red sound like an
engine okay okay
max arena to the max
great you sounded hammered and am i
hired
it's perfect it's exactly what we were
looking for we love it
uh the girl daddy we're here to talk
about
in your special interview welcome why
why call it uh girl daddy i feel like i
know a little bit just from watching the
special
yeah i've been called a female comic so
many times that if i have kids i'm only
answering to girl daddy
that's the only thing i'll answer too
yeah we're gonna go out of our way
to feminize these titles yes
then i'm gonna be you know it originated
actually from my nephew
it's something that he called my sister
his girl daddy
yeah he's like you're my girl daddy and
you're like that's mine
and this kid gets no money yeah and i'm
like look i can't live my life without
mining it for material
so yeah what is the true thing that
happens is like
i noticed how often it doesn't even
clear things up when they bring some up
as a female comedian if anything
it brings the show to a grinding halt as
the show
hosts stumbles all over it yeah that's
jimmy
we have to catch up watch out for those
raiders all right next oh
god we got a female
girls behave yourself women get out of
the room don't watch your cycles to link
up we got a female
comic coming to the stage like they're
so baffled that someone
with different parts is going to do the
same job as that
it's kind of one of those things where
uh i get
i don't know what to say like we have to
maybe stop talking about it
like how are we still having the
conversation like why would i still be
getting asked the question
what's it like being a female comic i
feel like we're self-perpetuating at
this point
um yeah sorry this is getting serious
and we're looking for some real
quick bites it's asked so you have to
think about it because it is asked in
interviews and
sometimes the only way to get into these
articles is like comment on what it's
like being a female comedian
right and it's like we've been freaking
doing it for a long time when i was
younger i used to answer the question
like
it's great it's an advantage i stand out
on a lineup blah blah blah
and then lately i've heard from some
other females
that they don't appreciate that and that
we should be talking about that it's
more difficult or whatever it is or the
problems with it and it's like
i don't know what it'll stop females
have been killing oh maybe i should have
shut my door before this interview
i no you have movers coming in you're
being evicted
you're a comedian in 2020 so you're
being currently evicted
also congrats on the special thank you
so much the movers are going to be
installing your furniture in half
yeah well we're doing this interview to
promote the special
um a lot of things are being repo'ed
from me
yeah is there someone else no longer
afford it it's happening
should i shut my front door the front
door yeah
shut the front door is
is this a bit shut the front door okay
yeah
it's been checked hbo max is just like
hbo but it's very clean
it's hbo for christians wait a minute
a lot of succession is heavily edited
somebody somebody was like when are we
gonna get a family friendly hbo special
it's like
is that what they're known for the hbo
special genre
family friendly well this special is for
the hoes and the dirty dogs out there
pretty special folks i'm thankful i got
it in
moses i i would be freaking out if i
were you i'm sorry i'm even drawing
that's very fair i mean we're talking
about earlier
we have yet to tape our specials and
it's like i don't know how
we're going to do it i'd much rather be
in your position i was listening to sets
before this to remember
what life was before remember what
stand-up was
and because i knew we were going to talk
about this special but i do feel so
disconnected from it but
it gave me the memory of like we are so
lucky to do our jobs and be what they
are and i don't know if i
really was thinking of it that way but
i'm listening and i'm like this hour
especially
i am i worked really hard to even have
the stage be close to the audience i'm
very connected to the audience
um i'm touching them at times i mean not
like
a lot you put your fingers in people's
mouths
i mean i will say super spreader but you
recorded this in february
right before the shutdown and also
yeah we'll just finish this one thought
it is insane well my special's not gonna
work it's all talking about how come
concerts are so crowded these days
i'm always getting bumped but you're
special
it's very connected with the crowd you
have a great stage set up where you it's
like a comedy club where people are on
each side of you
you're ready to even talk to the
audience do i have to pick in the first
four minutes i doubt i i have to pick
someone that's going to kind of stay
with me throughout throughout the
special
a man i thought in this particular
special
that man is jeremy but i had many men
throughout the tour
that helped me wow but i had to make
that choice within like
you know i come out i'm looking up you
know how it goes you you see your crowd
you're looking at him you're looking for
the right
guy to pick you almost have to pick
someone who's not frightfully shy
but he looks gentler and a teeny shy
because you want them to know that they
are going to be in good hands so many
people hate sitting up front because i
think they're going to get destroyed
um not my goal at your show absolutely
look at this guy look at your eyebrows
too thick my man weren't you sick right
before
oh my gosh i was i think i got sick
in chicago in january i must have picked
something up i was traveling
and touring you know like three months
straight
um in preparation and i got sick in
january
which is dangerous time yes yeah i was
just kicking around iraq in 2004.
that's such a loaded answer we were sick
in january
yeah exactly and it
felt like i couldn't get rid of it and
so of course i don't
want to be one of those people who's
like i already had it but i'm telling
you i got sick in january i couldn't
shake it
i feel like i'm gonna get it
[Laughter]
oh my god
100 one oh no
96 you're clear cheers to our true drink
minimum
thank you 96 years this is official
testing this is better than the testing
that we already have
like maybe it's stress and travel of
touring leading up to it
and but i do like i like to do vocal
warm-ups i come from a musical family
and so i was your mom is a music teacher
right
that's right so we always did some we
did classic warm-ups
did you want me to do it for you yes
please i need some vocal warm-ups
mommy made me mash my m m's
mommy made me mash my m m's
that was pretty good bum bum daddy made
me
cry myself to sleep dump
on me cry myself to sleep you seem
uh sisters maybe yeah this i took uh
some liberties sisters made me feel real
insecure
made me feel real insecure you know most
of the time is like unique new york
the last one will really i think appeal
to you the first time i
had sex was with a doll
i had sex was with a doll
very personal to me
are these not universal i've never heard
them they sound
uh they sound legit though and take it
from the special you have humped
inanimate objects so i'm guessing the
doll is coming from real life
sometimes i would cheat on the couch at
the end of the bathtub
i was a bit of a humper i guess
here and there it's something i've been
open about um because i was never
described to you
no i think yes i don't know
if you were ever taught it depends on
how your parents taught you
sexuality i know some parents discuss
masturbation with their
with their kids um i remember in my
special you'll remember
that we had a health teacher that talked
about teaching their
sons how to masturbate which i thought
was illegal but
if i had been able to get ice cream
after that can you
that's such a weird mine was like very
religious parents it was very repressed
it was never going to get talked about
so i just feel like pieces from tv and
then well now instagram
is screaming were your parents heard
repressed about it was your mom like
that's fine
no my mom never caught me i think if she
caught me humping the
couch maybe we'd have talked about it
but
now she never made me feel bad or guilt
or anything it was less
i think it was just more of a not
totally discussed thing
than you shouldn't be doing certain
things yeah
how's your mom feel about your stand up
hmm we had a discussion about this
recently especially in regard to to sex
and talking about it because when i
first started i was very much like
uh very aware of the stereotypes of
female comics like that unfortunately
still exists
13 years later which are women only talk
about sex and so i was like i'm not
gonna talk
about sex i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
repeat jokes and i won't sleep with any
comics
um those were my rules when i first
started at 22. yeah
you know i kept those for a while um
but then i think you become a grown
woman it's like well why can't i offer
my perspective on this it doesn't have
to be some sort of
exploitative graphic description of sex
but um i think it can only help to have
more people's perspective on their
experience and my mom looks at it like
yeah she she doesn't love but she calls
it like body parts humor
like she doesn't love cussing about your
bathroom parts on stage
but i think she's also just like you're
a grown woman and um
some of this isn't going to be for me
all right cheers congratulations on the
special i mean it when i say it's really
great i
highly recommend it girl daddy hbo max
thank you beth for joining us